et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon bah c'était la saint valentin je dis
ouais bah fait préférer cette fête où je
pense à toutes ces femmes qui j'ai posé
un lapin une veste et pour les plus
chanceuses une blennorragie
parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
donner je suis là pour les guider
25% de leur dette élevée entre whaou
today gaspard proust
casino
je rends compte lorsque les gens ils
râlent en ce moment a way le
gouvernement c'est le sociétal qui
masque le social au lieu de faire le
mariage gay en ferez mieux de résoudre
le problème du chômage et
résoudre le chômage ça fait 30 ans qu'on
essaye à un moment faut savoir perdre
[Applaudissements]
puis via diaby a des trucs bien mariage
gay c'est tellement enfin enfin un
gouvernement qui se soucie d'amour
d'amour [ __ ]
tu vois quoi l'amour quoi enfin le ps il
fournit l'amour la crise et fournit
l'eau fraîche quand on était bien
[Applaudissements]
sk par un moment on peut parler d'autre
chose que de fric et déficit on peut
juste puis refuser la pma quelle
connerie il faut faire des gosses sinon
qui va payer les dettes de nos parents
c'est les vases communicants viol un bon
pour d'autres c'est une époque terrible
c'est vrai qu'on sent que les gens
perdent leurs repères parce que ce type
qui s'est immolé devant pôle emploi moi
j'ai eu très peur je veux dire ah non
puis après je dire c'est pas grave le
pape n'est pas boudhiste donc
non mais franchement le type il se croit
ou au tibet à belleville le type il est
en france me faire le printemps arabe un
moment il faut choisir son camp alors
les gens sont choqués parce qu'il aurait
prévenu les gars de pôle emploi et ces
derniers n'auraient rien fait pour
empêcher le massacre il n'allait quand
même pas intervenir à cause d'une torche
humaine comme jeudi pour une fois qu'il
y avait une lumière au pôle emploi
[Applaudissements]
et les politiques dans tout ça que font
les politiques alors hollande remonte
dans les sondages ça c'est grâce à la
guerre ou un mariage gay chacun son
fonds de commerce étaient à sarko
l'identité nationale hollande l'amour
sous les douches bon
alors il se murmure que sarko va revenir
en 2010 est il pas bien pas bien faire
des conférences à 100000 euros et rêver
de rouler en bx
mais bon ça va être un truc des gosses
et par rapport à la france c'est le
pouvoir c'est comme ça et puis voir l'an
passé on regrette plus facilement son ex
quand on la retrouve au bras d'un tocard
[Applaudissements]
l
opc ils ont supprimé la faucille et le
marteau c'est vrai que vu que le pc
représente surtout des bataillons de
chômeurs il aurait dû le remplacer par
une télécommande et un paquet de chips
ça aurait
été plus adapté parlons d'eux parlant de
scolarité de politique le cas de cet
élève qui se faisait harceler à l'école
parce qu'ils étaient roue et il s'est
suicidé vraiment malheureuse histoire
alors il se faisait harceler depuis
trois ans on reproche aux profs de pas
avoir agi moi je comprends pourquoi les
profs ont laissé faire bien pour une
fois que c'est pas hugo callas et bien
alors je pense à la prochaine rentrée
scolaire en salle des profs étoiles
cette année ils sont comment à 20 c'est
dur et toi à moi ça va dans la classe ya
un gros
handicap
je veux évidemment parler de foot
un international français serait à
nouveau impliquée dans une relation avec
une prostituée mineure alors le
footballeur joue dans le championnat
russe qu un moment jouer en russie et se
faire gauler avec une prostituée
française faut le faire c'est comme
aller un défilé dior est rentré avec
cécile duflot n'en sais rien
[Musique]
c'est passé pas le seul c'est un peu la
saison des footballeurs qui sont gaulle
et patrice evra lui s'est fait gauler
avec une escort girl corrige les gens
sont étonnés ils comprennent pas assez
il pensait quoi qu'ils allaient
s'inscrire à l'amour est dans le pré
jeudi on n'allait quand même pas le
retrouver avec une femen savès et les
pussy riot sang l'oreille musicale
alors ils ont fait une manif dans notre
dame de paris alors c'est super engagé
c'est vrai que avec le vrai courage des
feymen séquelles aux exhibé des
poitrines qui ferait déborder dsk
bah oui moi je comprends qu'avec des
saints pareil on en veille à dieu
c'est ça de grandir à l'ombre de
tchernobyl
ça pousse où ça ne pousse pas
et si ça pousse selon moi je comprends
en fait c'est pas de la provoc quoi la
provoc ça suppose un danger quand je dis
retraités le pape de nazis ou se
promener nu dans une église c'était la
provoc ce que l'accrobranche est à
l'alpinisme quoi c c'est de l'adrénaline
avec le confort bourgeois quoi de la
verveine rome faut arrêter alors
certains se disent mais pourquoi au lieu
de faire du tam-tam sur les cloches et
font pas ça dans une mosquée mais c'est
pas possible la cloche dans une mosquée
ça s'appelle un imam
[Applaudissements]
façon moi me taper une féministe j'avais
été un truc pour la féministe c'est la
féministe pour une lesbienne c'est du
gingembre pour un mec c'est du
topinambour c'est pas pour l'emploi
benoît 16 quel gâchis toi on le pape
donc c'est ce type qui vient une fois
par an montrer au monde entier que le
latin est toujours mort
il parle 15 langues c'est ce qui
explique sans doute pourquoi il n'y aura
jamais de paepe français
alors le type il a présenté sa démission
en latin preuve qu'il est complètement à
la rue parce que le type qui gère 2
milliard de fidèles il s'adresse à cinq
cardinaux et aux trois classes prépa en
hypokhâgne
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pour faire ma petite langue de
[ __ ] mais j'espère que le prochain pape
sera noir ouais c'est juste pour voir si
ceux qui l'ont traité de nazi auront
l'audace de traiter le prochain doudou
[Applaudissements]
gastronomie moi je moi j'en peux plus le
cheval j'en peux plus quand je pense que
ça fait une semaine que l'actualité est
monopolisé par une [ __ ] de sauce
bolognaise
pas l'europe qui à la renverse à cause
d'un plat cuisiné enfin déjà le plat
cuisiné faut voir ce que c'est c'est
quoi ces essais du vomi gratiné tous
ceux qui en mangent en fait on vient de
sortir une logan en plats cuisinés ça
s'appelle des lasagnes à la roumaine
les gens s'étonnent du caractère cacher
il aurait pu prendre le pli quand la
roumanie c'est quand même tout ce qui
est un peu caché enfin je le slogan de
la roumanie c'est quoi ces cancers
humains ces clandestins
après on s'étonne que cette viande et le
goût de voyage je suis désolé les
roulottes sont pas tirées par des
charolais
non c'est une polémique très indécentes
sur la viande sa conscience surtout les
pauvres bon et c'est eux qui achètent
des plats cuisinés bon et franchement
être au chômage et pas avoir le temps de
cuisiner
[Musique]
alors l'année et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus